You're gonna feast on this one conceptuality is something other than itself. There's been
a change in the image of thought. That's what it is. That's what it is. That's what it is. The
internal structure of but as soon as an utterance slips from the mouth it's divorced from the
subject for me the biggest thing in this the paradigmatic example for this for me in Plato's
pharmacy has been the Egypt stuff like i've read that essay five or six times let's say in my life
and i had never really paid attention to the Egypt stuff like that that whole chunk on the Egyptian
mythology other you know i scanned it and i kind of i'm like okay yeah it's references i didn't realize
like how important it is right for this whole notion of what counts as a text right like so is this in
Plato or is it not in Plato and is it logic i mean you know the problematizing of the mythos logos
distinction it's like oh my god that Egyptian stuff is like it's absolutely central he never
left the text never left the text right but it feels i mean at least for me for the first few
times in reading it it was like oh yeah this is some so this is Derrida showing that he did his
homework and finding a couple of interesting connections um but it's like no it's actually
this is is this in the text or is it not in the text why or why not like what and really especially
for the whole mythos logos distinction it's like if the if the logic of the father son and all that
like the relations are implicit in the mythology or explicit in the mythology then that is like
that's assumed you know in in um in general into logos right like so this whole question of a
even a distinction between not not even an opposition but just a distinction between them just becomes
impossible to maintain right right like the mythos logos story is like it's just it just becomes
ridiculous like there aren't two different things right there is just a mishmash of you know difference
right right well i mean i think in terms of doing this for an episode you know this text is so familiar
to the all three of us that you know we've read it taught it you know like written on it that right
the question fittingly you know for a lot of different reasons is where do you even start with
something like this in terms of recording an episode on it right well i mean i also feel like
you know on on some level we could just talk about the first page right like the the first page and
the issues of textuality that he sets up there are you know like and i the the assignment that I gave
the class and this worked really well is because i you know talked through i told you what i've been
doing of like taking notes whatever i had them do that only with the first page so this was my first
time giving them an exercise a writing exercise so they did that with the first page and so the first
like 20 minutes of class was them reading what they'd come up with on the first page so my summary of the
first page was just summary stuff and i'm like i'm gonna let you guys cover the first page and then i'm
gonna cover the next 50 you know um so which was fine i mean it worked out fine and they they loved it i
well i mean to the extent that you could ever glean that but they it was it was definitely generative
for everyone who at least tried to do it
how often is the pharmakon actually mentioned or alluded to in the text in Plato's text itself like
is this a classic example of deconstruction where Derrida takes seemingly a small sort of
part or function of a text and articulates it as constitutive of the entire movement of the text
itself or is the pharmakon actually sort of a central theme that's i mean that's one of the
arguments he makes early on yeah right as he says like look this isn't just a thing that's an add-on
at the end of the text yeah it actually is called for from one end to the other so when he first
introduces the myth like the the word is there in in in multiple places yeah um so it's yeah but it's
right like really early on but it's never been interpreted in this way right like readings of the
pages have never done this yeah yeah okay okay yeah like i mean because traditionally the um the
attention to writing is thought of as an appendix something that's unnecessary in fact in a lot of
scholarship you know the entire second half of the dialogue is sort of superfluous you know which
is again like either because he's too young or too old you know this is a badly formed dialogue and
that it's really about it's about love it's about eros yeah the real takeaway is the um uh the mythic
charioteer that's the sort of like key content and then sort of like in the back half you know he
is either sort of he's just sort of like shaking his fists at the sophists because screw them yeah
that's the way it's i think most frequently taken up right right but you know and then the
The the iron, I mean, the irony I think in terms of the rhetoric folks is that, like, the second half is
just straightforwardly about the Sophists, right? Like, it's it's the tone has totally changed.
Right, there's a much more didactic relation between Socrates and and Phedrus, um, but I love, I mean,
honestly, I I really have always felt when I teach it that that one paragraph where he says, uh, like
the hypothesis of a well-formed, um, uh, text naturally reveals new concordances, right? Like, the point at
which you just stop presuming that it's a bad text, right? Because the two halves don't hang together
is the point at which you start discovering stuff, and like to me that's just the like as a life ethics.
I mean certainly as a textual ethics, but also just in general, like pretend for a moment this thing is
really well done, right? Like pretend that it's organized well, even if you think that it's organized
poorly, pretend it's organized well, and what will happen is you're going to find that there's interesting
resonances, connections, developments, right? Like I mean as a as a sort of ethics of generosity in terms
of how certainly how one reads, but also just encountering others. Like, hey, I think that's a
shitty thing. It's like, what what if it wasn't? What if it wasn't a mistake, right, right? And it's not
about like it actually being well put together or not being shitty, right? Like, it doesn't it doesn't
matter. It ends up actually just thoroughly being a heuristic, but as frankly, and but that's the cool
part to me is even if you begin from the heuristic sort of instrumental approaches, I'm going to approach
this as if, as you get into it, you start going like, and you start discovering these these connections
and relations, and you start going, well hold on a second, maybe maybe I'm not treating it as if,
maybe I'm actually discovering something that was there that I was unable to see because I assumed
it was poorly constructed, and that's exactly to me the point that he wants you to get at, which is
like you stop knowing what the text is yeah, right? Like, it's is this me doing this to the text or is
this the text doing it to me? And that's the whole point of that first page is like those are bad choices,
right? Like, it's not going to be subject object relation, that's the the nexus of of you know
whatever reader text that uh conjunct, and again that's even a bad way of saying it, right? Because
it presumes the pre-existence of these discrete entities, but it's that nexus where you're like
I don't know if this is me doing this to the text, the text doing this to me because those are
those categories aren't adequate. Like, you realize the extent to which you know the critique of
intuitionism in here, like the things that I think that I think fundamentally are produced
right? And that to me those things have huge implications for how you fucking live in the
world, right? Like sure, well it's created a far more ambiguous Plato for me sitting right, like sitting
with the the the Phaedrus and writing on it so long is that you know like at some in some ways you
know if I were going to distill it, you know, the you know Plato was traditionally taken up as as you know
this is the the dialogue on love. Derrida shows that, you know, in spite of Derrida that that this is
actually about the pharmacon, the problem with the supplement, and Plato seems to be trying to, it's an
attempt to like to control the thing, but what is demonstrated is that it's ultimately uncontrollable,
and then the longer I sit with it I'm like, I don't know if it's simply in spite of him that like you
know that like that, um, at the very end of Plato's Pharmacy where he gives that little, um, sort of
parable of of Plato's Pharmacy of imagining Plato in in the pharmacy messing around with all of the
chemical concoctions and you know loses control over them, you know, I increasingly see that as him not
losing control over them but sort of like carefully experimenting with the like like with with the
you know, with the material on on hand, and and like I don't i truly don't know if that's me seeing
that, if that's Plato doing that, if that's only is able to emerge in response to Derrida, right? So
and and the ambiguity is not a problem for me. In fact, I dread losing that ambiguity. Yeah, yeah, right.
And and you know what's interesting to me because I was very conscious when I taught this a couple of
weeks ago, I was very conscious of your of your reading, right? Because I you know and that that because
to me you're reading kind of twist the screw one more, like one more turn. So instead of in spite of
Plato his the pharmacon does these other things, you're sort of saying it's not in spite of Plato
that's what Plato is doing, right? And so reading Derrida this time for the most part it is a tone of in
spite of Plato, but there are absolutely moments in there yeah where he's just like no no no Plato is
fucking setting this thing on fire, right? Like Plato is provoking by bringing it into being Plato is
provoking the play of oppositionality that, that's the that's the game that Plato is playing in that regard
you know yeah i'm like whoa so so and that's an interest that's interesting for me because that comes
i in my for me that came from your reading the thing like period right like that's where i first thought
that thought uh and yet i now see it in Derrida's right now and i'm like okay you know so we got these next
levels i know it mixes yeah whose is that but is that and especially because my capacity to read
it this way only happened because you were my supervisor right so that's even that's even weird
that's even more impossible it's like right right but is it is is Nathaniel's is your more generous
reading is that attributing agency to Plato like is that is that being more generous to Plato than
Derrida is or is it sort of just saying in some ways what Derrida is at points like you mentioned John
that the text allows for these complexities to emerge like even when he's trying to control them
via opposition like that still allows for the play of of the concept in the way that you're saying is
i was just gonna say like i was just gonna say like i see the Plato less as like the person with
intentions and just more like what the sort of the the text is is doing right and so the the way that
Derrida often but not always articulates the text is like losing control of its attempt to control
itself right but why not you know like but let's take the next step why not go to Plato's intentions why
not say like seriously well why not to me the next step is like well if it's textuality so are his
intentions yeah right they are not something extra texture and so if that's the case why not say no
no no this is Plato meant to do this like yeah that makes just as much sense right right certainly
possible but like but for it's far more interesting for me to think of it through like the functioning of
the dialectic right is that you know the way that Derrida and Deleuze and others tend to think about
the dialectic because it's a stabilizing mechanism right it needs to find the the the the proper
source on which to it's like it's like the uh Descartes project you know you need to find find
the sure foundation that you can then build on yeah and the more i engage like the the like the Socratic
dialectic that like any of Plato's dialogues it's just more like no these are machines that run ad
infinitum that that they are constantly whatever they touch they remake and they remake again and
again and again and again and again and you know so much of Plato scholarship i read it's always about
like the question is always where do we stop right where like did this dialogue get to that firm
foundation did it get to it and then move beyond it and have some kind of supplement that wasn't
important you know usually somewhere around like two-thirds of the dialogue you know like the the
foundationalist reader of Plato will say like aha he got to it there you know like it's in you know
like in the Gorgias it's in the articulation of you know that analogy between um uh the arts of
maintenance and and medicine and the arts of like um sophist or like judgment and like the the spiritual
and bodily arts like thing and then it's like everything else after that is just an elaboration
of that and i'm increasingly reading it's like no everything after that is a mutation of that
right and and has no stand the mutations never have a stopping point the dialectic is that kind of like
is is like a a um you know the the mad scientific invention like an intervention into something
there's the perpetual adding of a supplement it's never about finding a short ground and so like if
you want to attribute like like yeah that's what Plato did over and over like how does how does something
like the law of the excluded middle never ever ever find a stable ground because it is right
right right that's the only thing that ever happens all right yeah right so in that sense you could say
perhaps that the Phaedrus is not about establishing some sort of foundation for philosophy or for life
or for ethics but it's about it's literally about the play of textuality like that is about anything
it is doing the play of textuality it is doing it is doing the living of thoughts right yeah but in that
sense the content would have to be like you would be reading the content through that style like through
that style or movement like they wouldn't you wouldn't be separating them from each other so even
when he's talking about oppositions that seem he seems to be instantiating some sort of foundational
concept like the thread is textuality and movement which is what runs through it yeah you know one way
of one way of invoking movement is to install oppositions yeah all right yeah and you really
i mean i really get the again i haven't read Plato in a while but like you really get the sense in
Hegel that he is at moments trying to establish some sort of ground but then the text writes itself like
He writes himself out of the ground sentence after sentence right and it sort of spirals that way
And I'm sure you could read Plato that way as well well this is like I was just gonna say the
differentiation between Plato in the writing becomes a very problem that's where the the the distinction
between the two becomes far less interesting like like it's not not Plato but it's not Plato either
that you know like one version of Plato might really want to find that foundation but the other
version of Plato that is committed to running the dialectic never ever allows him to do it
You say the same thing about Hegel yeah but that's that's where I like I mean I'm getting to this
point I don't really like it yet but I'm working my way to this point I kind of like locating it in
Plato the person like as an as a kind of next move which is like make the intention with all of the
caveats that we'd have to make right but make the intentional argument because Plato's intention
would be the very movement that we're talking about so why not say Plato's intention was to set this
movement into place and and how about how about this Plato's conscious intention in other words like
even narrow it down to that again we'd have to do lots of provisions about how we're using those terms
yeah why not even why not even go there right like it's and because I think that Derrida at some level
almost is because he's like this is conceptuality this is not fucking like Plato is just a sort of
place where we're you know locating this and working this through Hegel could be another one right like
I mean seriously there's no no I see it in that regard no difference right like um and so you know
like why not just say rather than thinking as as I always have is that Derrida was claiming that
despite uh Plato's intentions and goals writing itself has this wild force and it's like it's rather
reframe that thing and think of Plato's intentions as being constituted by that wild force writing yeah
yeah right so there is no domestication now here's the thing that I think is important is that there
is a particular value structure that comes out of Plato that is not simply writing which is sort of
paternity originality like all of these sort of that particular hierarchy that emerges yes it's
undercut by writing but it's also established by writing and that doesn't have to be the case
like what while one can't get rid of the movement of difference in writing that constitutes that
sort of wild movement one can produce a wild movement differently right like with a different
arche let's say well I mean I think just to slow down what you were saying before is that one problem
of like the concept of the death of the author is it installs too final of a dot binary between the writing
yeah and that's right and right because now it's the text now we say it's the text itself that does this
it's like no it's not the text itself so if you begin with the proposition that the writer is
constituted by the writing of the text which means it's not it's not stabilized and independent of the
writing in either because it's the writing is just an instrument or because the writing is its own agency
neither because there is a particular communication between the two that is mutually constitutive
then something like intentionality emerges very differently and you could even just like
do some work on the word of like the the internalization of tension right that there is
a tension in tension oh that's good I like that like because because you know if you're a theory
person you have to put unnecessary dashes and slashes um but like there's an there like this movement
is only made possible by the convergence of you know it was maybe not an opposition but like you know
like some kind of desire to find a foundation and some kind of movement of that dialectical movement
of of sort of like creating and installing oppositions in order to reveal that foundation
and that the communication between those two is an intention and just the cool thing about that
intention is it produces perpetual movement yeah yeah a very particular style of perpetual movement
that yields itself with a concern for genealogy and and purity and all this right and that's
and it's but it's yeah but it doesn't have to right like it could be so you could say like yeah like
that intention could play itself out differently right like it doesn't have to have now what it has to
have it has to have hierarchy it has to have opposition it has to have a lot like it has to have all of
those quote-unquote freeze framing effects but it doesn't have to freeze frame them in this way like we could
have a maternal structure for example like as he points to in the Timaeus a little bit rather than a paternal
like and that would look different yeah but it would still be a structure it would still be organized
by logic it still be opposition like it would still have all of those you know predicates but
It wouldn't have the same kind of content, I guess. Well, I think, yeah, obviously there's various ways to
stabilize difference or orient towards difference, but I think, right, the difficulty of the Platonic
orientation is that it is at least generally speaking kind of an archetypical orientation, where like, where
difference, part of the conceptual dynamics of difference, is the domestication of difference.
So like that's right, you don't just get to openly play in the wildness of differential relations. You're
always making cuts and stabilizing and domesticating once you bring, I mean, he said there's a great
sentence in there. It's like once Plato brought it into being, right, meaning into actuality, then it was a game of
oppositions, right? Like, and so, and by the way, it's, that's even a bad way of saying it because it implies
that there's some pre like that's where you got to really own there is nothing difference really is
in a strict sense is difference really is nothing. There is not like some, because even when we talk
about it's like, well, there's this kind of movement there that pre-exists. Yeah, you know, the sort of
domestication, it's like no, there's no movement other than its instantiation of oppositions. That's it.
Right, right, right, yeah, it's not, it's not a transcendental ground of identity. Yeah, yeah, it is the movement of
identity, right, of identification, of exclusion, right, opposition. Yeah, yeah, but that's heady
shit, right? Like that, that become, that's I mean that's to me where I turn to Deleuze in terms of
the, like, honestly, that's the moment where I'm like, ah, Deleuze is easier for me to grasp on this, to think of
the virtual dimension that doesn't precede the actual is nothing other than its instance, you know,
that just becomes easier for me to think there. Well, I was just going to say that Spinoza's God, by
the way, I just real, I just realized that that's why he likes Spinoza. It's, that's the whole relation
of God and substance, it infinite, like, like, like, infinite potentiality, but, but infinite self-differentiate
yeah, infinite self-differentiating imminence, yeah, that's, that sounded really heady just just to clarify,
as long as, as long as that's something as a clarifying aside, it's infinite self-differentiating
difference, is that it, imminence? Sorry, I didn't want to fuck that one up. The scary thing is I followed
that, like, right? Yeah, yeah, um, but it does get like, look, one thing that Derrida, Derrida demonstrates over and
over and over again, this is sort of like the the the exhaustive, you know, move of of of um something
like, uh, deconstruction, is that, like, no binary holds, no nothing, no no no opposition holds, you know,
the right kind of scrutiny, everything falls apart, and you know, there's a certain existential terror with
that, that sort of just sort of like taps into a very long project of wanting to find some kind of
foundation you could probably crystallize that in something like in um, Descartes, uh, and then you
know that leads to the question of like, all right, you know, maybe like something like Richard Rorty, or
like pragmatism or something like that, we're like, all right, Wolfe or Camus, right, forget about finding
the grounds, find the provisional grounds that allow for a stabilizing world to to emerge, something that
you can you know, something that you can live with and okay, so that makes a certain amount of sense.
Um, except for I don't think they're grounds, right? Like I think performativity, yeah, like even even
um, provisional grounds doesn't go far enough, I think like the very concept of performativity
does away with that because you're never returning even to the same provisional grounds. No, is is that
like I think we have to just sort of like radically amp up repetition. That's why repetition becomes the key
word, right? The right, it's it's not a ground, it's a repetition, you know, it's a it's an iteration of
a pre-existing performative. It's not, it's not a ground. We act as if, I mean, that is one of the
ways of substantivizing it, you know, but but for instance, it's like some of this does stick, paternalism
sticks. Yeah, right, like, but it sticks, but now it doesn't ground, right, right, it's stay, I mean, it sticks
differentially, but like it it doesn't stick as a ground, it sticks as a repetition of a hierarchical
dynamic that is instantiated and undercut in its instantiation every time, and yet nevertheless has a
resonance, right? Like you can look around, like we can look around at the ways that we think of things, and
the primary way we think of you know generativity is fatherhood, right? Like, yeah, and so it has that, that
kind of force, so that's the extent to which it just creates fucking fundamentally how we think, how
we desire, how we you know, all of those things are constituted, but I would say not fundamentally
just because what a father is changes every single time that that the generativity changes. Like it
really matters if you imagine, you know, like the generativity as you know, like um, Venus sprouting from
the head of of Zeus or this sort of like through the mediation of the womb and the and the externalized
Mother or like what's interesting, you know, like one bit here and hopefully we can talk about it this
time or next time is um the relationship that Derrida creates between the logos and the father and the
dependency of the father on the logos and the sort of like, you know, the problematics of of that, you know,
all the heavy quotation marks, you know, um, um, being employed here uh the metaphoricity of that if it
is a metaphor of that father-son relationship because in each one of these repetitions the the the
the location, the function, the value, the worth of the father is made differently, right? So like you're like
like, look, it doesn't have to run out according to hierarchy, um, it doesn't have to be run out according
to to to patriarchy, um, and i would go even further like and it never there's no stable thing called
patriarchy that can be repeated as a same. It's only ever being remade, right? Yeah, um, but it's being remade
with when within a certain premise. I mean that's the thing, like so i i still want to hold on that there
is a sense of stabilization in in the process of the sort of self-differentiation as well, right? Like
so there are different kinds. So this is the territorialization detail, like you know, becoming
territorialized isn't the worst thing that can happen to you, right? Like becoming de-territorialized is
death, right? Like this sort of absolute sort of chaos thing, and that there is a sense of stability
in the inheritance or in the repetition uh that is that is crucial, and and again you're totally right
to say and simultaneous with a self-differentiation and and it's that's that's where the condition of
impossible the condition of possibility is simultaneous simul it's hard to really think that it is
simultaneously, yeah, the condition of impossibility. It's not like you instantiate something and then it
falls apart, you know? Yeah. Well, i mean one i think we could turn to the reading writing stuff as the
same as a way of thinking that dynamic, but yeah, two the other things is it doesn't happen within
a confines. It doesn't happen like within parameters, and it's like that that very concept of stability
that is really interesting to me uh, like along like think about you know things that we generally think
about along the the general specific um, like like genre or like trope or like archetype, right? And we're
like oh well this is a repetition of the you know edible complex or you know or um, but you know what
to lose might call like molar entities, right? Uh, yeah, um, and i do think that that's the mechanism of
stability but i just think that the way that we think about stability the metaphors that we're using are
wrong because it's not about a same coming through. It's not about a hierarchical transcendent, you know,
pattern being then cookie-cuttered on top of something, right? Because you know i think we have to think
about the the the genre, the genus, as being subject to transformation and as iterative, that when you say
like you know, take a trope like the edible complex like the you know exacerbated mother whatever
like yeah, it's like there is a kind of there's i've always described as a kind of stickiness, like
there is like a recognizability, right? You can sort of like, you know, you can take all the blurred edges
and you can snap them into place like, yeah, i recognize that's right, yeah. But it is not the
same thing getting instantiated over no no i mean it has to be made the genre for instance has to be
made in the first instance and then has to be remade perpetually in order for there to be an existing
genre and you could you could translate that to like even just the notion of of selfhood as a genre of
being like, and Hegel does this really well, like, um, the what what he basically articulates is that
there's a there's a series of enduring pesky tendencies, you know, that that change, right? But
that the tendency kind of holds. So like if there's a tendency towards stabilization and you can think of
that in terms of subjectivity, like what is what does the subject do? It isolates itself, it establishes some
sort of boundary, right? And it it creates performatively an identity, um, but of course as you know, as we all
know, that's that's a perpetual performative movement that has no foundation or ground, right? You're just
saying the i like i am myself over and over and over again, and of course you change, but nevertheless
there is still but so does the eye right? So so does the generic thing being changed as well, like
i mean to yeah i mean i think it's so hard not to use transcendental language when talking about this
kind of stuff as if you know the genre you know exists hovers above, you know, it's it's instantiations
and it is where you know like the solutions into the flat playing makes a whole lot more sense where
you can imagine something like the eye as i think you were talking you were just saying this Nate as
like a a glut or an intersection that that like it has a i don't know a certain gravitational pull to
it but every single time you know there's any repetition any kind of anything traffics across it
the entirety of the eye changes right. I mean, but you know, it might just be a single, you know, like
tiny little change, but that would ripple throughout the entire notion of the eye like, you know, the eye is
not the eye is not the eye, right? This is like, we're like, forget about the law of the excluded middle.
The logic of identity, identity being the other one, yeah, but but for instance, I i get in, I i mean, I guess
i'm just kind of trying to hold on to or insist upon the importance of a continuity through the
those iterations, uh, rather than so for instance, what what doesn't happen is you don't wake up one day
and live at a different social structure, right? Like that doesn't, in other words, we don't just
like it's not an absolutely different, like there's a, there is a, I mean, you just use the word tendency
or a trend or a disposition or a style like that, and yes, every iteration is transformative even if some
sort of might like incredibly small, but and that's certainly true, and yet it's always
working in relationship to a prior uh repetition that it takes to be it takes itself to be repeating
in a uh, a recognizable identifiable way, right? It's never just like, okay, well i'm going to be me
tomorrow and that's going to be something just, you know, right? Wildly different, right? Yeah, or or a
different political system or different, you know what i mean? Like there's just so so much continuity
take take take differently, right, in the appropriative sense in in that um, okay, so think about the dynamic
between, you know, the i and me, right? And let's think about that as a continual process of
territorialization de-territorialization or as a continual back and forth of appropriation
right? Maybe that will point us to the kind of stability that we're we all i think, you know, can't
you know reason away, it's there somehow, right? So okay, so the i does not hover above me, right? It does
not every time i use i i am not invoking an archetypical typical i that then like, you know, then
cookie cutters me according to its logic, right? Um, you'd have to think about the i as operating on the
same point as as the appropriative like as the thing that it appropriates, them that's right. I and me, that's
right. Okay, so then now i'm going to turn to Nietzsche for this: is that like, you know, the the appropriation
is always operative in terms of active and reactive force. The art was like in terms of the i as an active
force, right? There is the like as a performative force, the i takes hold of the thing and um, and
and expresses its power through it, right? So in other words, i am subject to the eye, right? The form of the
eye, yeah. Okay, and then that uh, and then that interaction, you know, like the the reactivity of that exchange
then has a ripple effect back on back on to the eye, but also you got i i see what you're doing. You're
creating a fucking diagram like that thing from The Logic of Sense. I know you did, aren't you? That's what you're
actually doing right now. I just, well, I didn't know I was. I didn't know that I was doing it, but I feel
like I have to do it now, that's just what you're doing. Yeah, you're doing that right? No, you're right.
Right, this is The Logic of Sense battery thing, right? It is. Yeah, yeah, yeah, you're right. Um, okay.
Well that could actually be helpful now that I know, because I have no idea where i'm heading
uh with this, but like but I think we'd also have to think about that not as being a unidirectional
relationship in that you know the the eye can is can be performatively active, right? Take a hold of
something else and express its power through it, and that can also be performatively reactive
something else takes a hold of it, right? Like i don't know grammar and that's the sense yeah, but
see that's the sense in which and this will feed Nate uh perfectly. It's like the problem is thinking
relationally, right? Like because relation presupposes the terms, right? It's like if this is
this is prior and prior not temporally or not, it's not prior is the wrong word. It's like it's prior to
relationality, like relationality, like relationality is like the secondary
sort of manifestation. It's the it's the way consciousness makes sense of these things, right?
right? Like we're not even talking about relations, right? We we're just talking about a kind of uh, um
i don't even know how one would think about what's prior to relations or if we can. Maybe that's the
problem. Yeah, I mean, like, but it just feeds your broad thing. It's like relational ontology, that's so
fucking yeah. Well one of the one of the problems I think at least from this quasi Hegelian orientation
that I kind of take is that like the subject if you can take that as a provisionally as a thing that
exists if if the subject in Hegel desires not consciously unconsciously whatever you want to
call it non-consciously both consistency and inconsistency simultaneously and this is what
this is what like so right like in Hegel life requires disunity um but the paradox is that the subject
apparently are ostensibly desires unity as well but without that uh confrontation um of otherness
right there that's what propels life, but the the the weird contradiction within that movement is that
subjects seem to desire exclusion, opposition, and sort of distinctiveness but without the constitutive
indistinctiveness there would be no distinctions to to to be had to yeah to draw and to drive the desire
right right because it's like the the the form of the the formless ground in Difference and Repetition
right is that you know, like the the differentiating mark, the performative move, right, that you know the
appropriative act that takes from pure heterogeneity, pure difference, and then draws boundaries that are
never complete, could not be complete, right, but still like you know like that that sort of that fold, right
there's often the language for it, that fold creates a quasi-internal ecosystem that can produce
something like its own desires, that that you know like those and those desires for independence, right
are you know like ironically a death drive because independence would mean its own death, right right
but um and that's the weird thing with with Plato too because like right he seems to be desiring
control, unity, all of those like essence, that sort of stuff, but and like against the complexity or the danger
of difference but you know ironically like you require that difference in order to even have the facade
of identity or well if they yes that's that's in the second part that's really that issue is really hit
on is that the pharmacon is the word for the outside itself and there's an implicit fantasy of pure
absolute interiority in in Plato which of course is death right like i mean which it would you know so
the total non-relationality of whatever the monad uh would be right like although in that sense it's like
the monad then becomes like for me if you actually push that logic further why is that not Spinosistic
which is the monad would constitute all of life like the problem is that we think of monads as being subjects
you know instead of monad being like no totality like absolute totality and and self-differentiation
mm-hmm but yeah I you know there was a there was a moment when you were talking there where I just
it just occurred to me I was like I'm totally enjoying and hooking into this conversation and
like I can't imagine that anyone else in the world would give a fuck about anything that we've been
talking about for the last 45 minutes like seriously like it's like it's so not going to make sense to
anyone and I I'm not quite sure how I feel about on the one hand I kind of like that on the other hand I'm
like what yeah I mean we're just going super fast like super fast in our own internal lexicon of the
things that you know the three of us have read right right I I would say there's probably like five or
ten people who who could really yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah right and we made them all but it's great it's
great it's great I mean there's a kind of i mean I don't know it's like if we just go back to the
phenomenological register which I recognize as one particular stopping point but it's like that's
intimacy right like it is that sense of a kind of indistinction and it cut because every time you guys
talk you're saying things that I'm like oh I hadn't thought of it with that angle or that whatever
inflection and and that's really cool like I find that to be super generative and like simply
joyful right like I i do but I also get that it's like it's pretty monastic right because it is it is
pretty separated isolated off from you know even people who read this stuff I think I mean I you know
like I think that it's we share a lexicon that's really yeah it's specific for sure like Hegel, Deleuze,
Derrida right is is and nature yeah and nature right and look there there are other people who
have that lexicon not a lot there are the people who have that lexicon but they don't have the
emphases and the terminology from like the way we just shifted to de-territorialization and re-territorialization
or you know like just shift the terminology right right yeah but it makes me it really does make
me think like i kind of think it would be really cool to do a project on the relation between Hegel and
Plato right like and and in the way that we're talking about not like what is the same and
different between Hegel and Plato but like this sort of the operation of oh and also like Deleuze
let's put Deleuze in there as well like I mean that would be a really interesting sort of thought
experiment to think about um the ways assuming on a certain level all of them are kind of doing this
same kind of thing right like yeah um and are invested in very similar kinds of thinking as a
sort of dynamic of self-differentiating uh ambiguous rendering and also you know solidifying like that
that nexus uh as um and not as antagonists like that's to me the important thing is not like how are
they the same or different but just sort of thinking those those three you know folks together yeah
it'd be really cool i just increasingly cannot read Plato otherwise than that yeah no no no i get
that i get that yeah you know and especially that like Socrates project over and over and over is
knowing himself and the own yeah and the and there's only ever responses i don't and like i don't think i
could and that's kind of and and he never gives up on philosophy i don't think it's because of the failure of
i don't think it's because like the the promise of someday finally knowing himself you know i i really
think it's like this is the coolest fucking engine i've ever like i'm baking myself over and over and
over so we have to do that and i'm i'm so with you on that i'm totally with you remember i've been
saying for you like i i long for the day when i could start the graduate class by saying as everybody
knows Plato is the great champion right uh of rhetoric right like um i think that's in season
one i think we started yeah we started with that one um but here's the the next turn for me is we
have to also then say that for the people who that think that Plato is the enemy like yeah you know
what i mean like you have to be able to do that same kind of move with with that kind of thinking as
well yeah not identical at all but not simply opposed or different right i don't know how to
well those are it's really a difficult kind of reading and i'm going back to like because i have
a section on Hegel and Deleuze and like i didn't want to take the Zizekian approach which is just kind of
like mostly just reprimanding Deleuze for being like anti-Hegelian so i didn't want to do that and
neither did i want to simply say how they fit into some like how they're the same as you're saying so
you like the struggle was to distinguish some key moments right like that that might have resonances
but point to different emphases but then also see how they they resonate and i kind of i also tried
to do that with with Nietzsche and Hegel because they themselves they made those like Deleuze Foucault
Derrida they made that division so but to look at it more historically and not not in that like
sense of like a stark like i am departing fully from Hegelian thinking like that to me was productive
but it's it's really difficult to try to articulate that in an interesting way without falling into
without falling into like oh they're the same or compare and contrast yeah yeah yeah yeah it's a
difficult kind of writing this is where i this is it is a difficult right i mean i agree with you this
this is where i like come back to that mantra of Deleuze where it's like there is an Anti-Oedipus like
there's desire in the social and nothing else yeah right that's it and everything is a configuration
of you could even really say that there is just desire like right right like you don't even actually
yeah this the social gets you multiplicity so i get why they would want to do that right like
i think as soon as you have a desire you have the social
right no of course of course but right there's just a desire needs the projection of alterity and
as soon as you have heterogeneity and boom you're off to the races yeah yeah but and but but i think
that you're right like how do you write that or rather maybe for me the more practical question is
how do you write that and formulate that in a way that is doesn't simply rely on pre-existing
instantiations of here's Hegel here's Derrida here's Nietzsche you know what i mean like that's
that's the thing like how do you integrate and um what cut them up in ways that sort of produce
not seamlessness and not indifference you know but but in a non-recognizable sense of movement
i don't really know well i i try to think about them as vectors of approach like Hegel is a vector
of approach that is not going to be commensurate with you know Hegel writ large same thing with with
with Plato that's right and then stage the collection of a collection of vectors yeah not
just a vector right like 17 vectors 17 vectors so it's gonna be the 17 vectors which is still not
going to be adequate but like that's not the point there's only seven 17 vectors of Hegel and this enough
and uh well if it's if Hegel gets 17 there's 18 of no then the point of gets 32
you